In the first season, you saw us setting up this tent,
which was a massiveupgrade back then.
However, the tent started deteriorating massively over time.
Thecanvas is falling apart and the frame is not sturdy at all.
So, we will try to finda way to fix it in this episode.
But first, we will harvest some vegetables at Nuno'sfarm.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
- Today, some of us are heading over
to Nuno's farm to help with theharvesting.
We're bringing some crates
to collect our own fruit and vegetables.
It's not the first time we'vebeen here,
but it's always niceto have a tour of the farm.
So, first up: the animals.
They are an important part of the farm,
as the manure is used as fertilizer.
Welcome to Nuno's regenerative farm.
Nuno, what kind of farm is this?
- It's a wild farm of some kind.
A mixed farm, between gardening,
an orchard and a lot of different things.
It's anecological farm, because, yeah,
we leave a space for everything.
We have a pieces of soil digged...
Wehave grass...
We have dry things...
We have three small shrubs, and a bit of everything!
So, everyone finds a bit of food here.
And then, we generate a harmony,
where a lot of food remainsfor us still as well.
- Nuno's goal is to create a farm as an ecosystem that is self-sustaining.
Creating space for multiple types of vegetation, insects and wildlife.
And therefore, creating a moreresilient ecosystem.
This is called regenerative farming, which we already saw in update 90.
Theprinciple is to create rich soil and diversify crops.
So, there's no need for chemical inputs,
to fertilize and protect the plants from pests.
We are excited to help out and learn from him!
But, we came to help harvesting, so here we go.
After a few hours of harvesting, we filled upthe crates
and we're ready to head back to Kamp.
Nuno, are you happy with the harvesting help?
- Yuuuup!
Until next time!
- After the harvest, we have a lot of tomatoes.
We thought it would be good to make
some sauce for the pizza night.
But first, we are going to renovate the tent.
- So, here we are, underneath a white tent.
You can see it is totally breaking down
and we are doing a fix on it.
This whitetent has been here since
the first season of Project Kamp.
It has been giving a great service to the Kamp.
So much that it becomes a very messy warehouse.
On top of that, the biggest problem isthe
intense sun and rain that ruined the canvas.
It has many holes and we already patched some of them.
But, it's still very ripped, which also produce a lot of microplastics.
Not good for the environment!
Maybe not the best solution for the outdoor...
Besides that, the frame is getting wobbly andunstable.
So, we need to fix that too.
Before we start, we need a new tarp.
So, Dave and Adrian went toa scrapyard,
to look for second-hand one.
There's a lot to choose from,
but itwas hard to find one in good condition...
Finally, we found a blue tarp, which is very dirty,
but still in good shape.
We put itin a pickup, and went back to Kamp.
Now, we can start working!
So, on the tarp, wefound a lot of these stainless steel brackets,
which are still quite usable and quite strong!
But, the thing is they are secure by
a really rusty screw that is unscrewable...
So, I guess that's we have to grind it out.
This tarp actually comes with alot of these roller metal parts.
They need to be removed, before we can reuse them.
- Is it complicated to take it out?
It's tricky, time-consuming and rusty, but doable.
Now that the wheels and bucklesare out, we can measure the top.
After checking on the tarp, wefound there are
different part with damages.
So, these are theareas that we will be avoiding.
We did some measuring onthe size of the tarp.
It is 13 meters (≈ 43 feet) long,
and around a 2.7 meters (≈ 9 feet) width.
We are going to see how we are going to cut and use it.
In order to do that, we need toclear the old white tent,
so we can measure it too.
Thanks Julie!
Now, some last measurements.
Now, we have measured the roof size,
and nowit's come to the cutting of the banner.
Exciting!
We have put the tarp onto the structure,
butthere's a lot of dirt on top of it.
So, we decide we need to clean a little bit.
Otherwise, we will worrythat the mud will
actually break the sewing machine...
With the material that big, it's very difficult
to push into the sewing machines.
This is one attempt on rolling it bothsides,
so it can enter the machine.
We can do a stitch in the middle right here.
I'm not sure if it works, but we'll see!
So, because the material is super big,
we need abig platform to put it on to do this sewing
The only big and flat surface is the platformof the kitchen.
Let's try to work in here!
So, now we have put a machine here,
and thematerial is inside of the machine.
Now, we try to sew...
I can't use the sewing machine ina proper way.
The canvas is too big to push in.
It's very thick, and I had tosteer it by hand,
just so the needle won't break.
This is the most frustratingmoment in the whole season...
So, we broke one needle already,
and weare now using our last needle.
We only have two.
If it breaks, we have to do hand stitching...
We just did one stitch, and now we're going
toturn it around and do another one.
It is very difficult and exhausting work.
Ittook us four hours just to sew six meters of tarp!
The sewing machines appear to be
reallystruggling on doing the second stitching.
So, I think we need another approach...
Instead of sewing, we're now tryinga different approach.
Which is using rivet and putting a spacer underneath it,
to pull two layers of fabric together.
Let's do it!
Phew! It works, and now we have a one big piece of fabric!
So, I guess this is time to saygoodbye to the white fabric?
Now, we needsomething to attach it to the ground.
So, these are two of the seat belt taken out from the yellow van.
We're trying to take it apart, get the strap out,
for trying to use it to strap down the tent.
Let's see how it goes!
Okay, so...
We have cut this double-sided part,
sowe can use it as a strap to hold the tent down.
We are making this little tap that goesunderneath the top.
For it to grab onto the metal frame.
So, now, we are attaching it!
Now that the tarp is attached to the frame,
it seems it will hold and not fly away.
We hope so!
So, now the almost finalpart is to add this strap onto the tarp.
It will act as a pullingforce, to hold the whole tent down.
The last step will be putting on the legs
andfasten the tent to the ground, just so it's tight.
With the buckles we got fromthe tarp, it is super easy to do!
The last strap is downand it is done!
- Nice work!
So, the old white tent is gone.
It has been veryuseful for us.
But, besides the structure,
the fabric wasn't going to last much longer.
Now, itseems like it has come back to life with this blue tarp!
The material is thick and resistant.
It'squite difficult to work with, but we've managed with it.
It feels like it's gonna last forever.
We havesome leftover material,
so we can use it for the next project.
Let's see!
It is great to givea second life to this material,
although we have to throw away the white top.
Even theold yellow van seat belts have a new use!
The space underneath is now empty and ready for new use.
- A super cool tent!
Now, we are going to the kitchen to make some tomato pulp.
For that, we need Dorian.
- So, today we're making tomato pulp.
We got these lovely tomatoes from Nuno's farm.
And then, we have alot of tomatoes for pizza night.
So, now that we've boiled our tomatoes,
I'm gonna blend this with this mixer.
The next step then would be toput it into the bottles.
So, let's go!
Now, I need to fill up the bottles, when the sauceis hot.
Then, it cools down and creates a vacuum,
so there's no more space for bacteria to growinside.
And, it stays good for a longer time!
And now, after collecting the tomatoes at Nuno's farm,
and after a long week of work...
We canenjoy this tomato sauce at pizza night.
Alright! That was it for this update!
If youalready want to watch the next update,
you can support us on Patreon.
If not, youcan see us next week.
Same time, same day!
Ciao!